today's video was made possible by
Masterworks more on this in a moment
what if I told you that there is a
country in Europe that is making money
from the energy crisis a democratic
country a member of NATO and one that
has gas and oil in abundance that's
right Norway the land of salmon and
black metal
after the shutdown of Russian gas many
eyes are on Norway a country that until
now was Europe's second largest source
of natural gas after Russia but the
million dollar question is will Norway
be able to save Europe with its gas
whatever the case one thing that is
clear is that Norway is getting even
richer from the war and this matters
because Norway is not only important for
oil it also has huge influence in the
business world that's right
despite having just over 5 million
inhabitants the Norwegian state has one
of the largest investment funds in the
world the Norwegian Sovereign wealth
fund much of the profits they earn from
fossil fuels are invested in assets all
over the world renewable energy plants
debt real estate and shares in the
world's largest companies and this could
have very significant consequences for
the day-to-day lives of all of us even
in areas we might never suspect so what
does Norway have to do with the fake
news on Facebook what does Norway have
to do with the Union struggles at Amazon
I haven't gone crazy by the end of this
video you will understand why everything
that happens in Norway could have
consequences on Wall Street and in our
daily lives
of course there have been no shortage of
those who have accused the Norwegians of
being selfish such as the Polish prime
minister but in Norway they all know too
well that you don't get rich by giving
money away in fact despite being a big
oil supplier they have one of the
highest gasoline prices in the world so
the questions we are asking today are
how is the war in Ukraine affecting
Norwegians what impact could this have
on the world economy today we're going
to answer these questions but before we
go on let me ask what's your favorite
horror movie mine is The Shining
sorry I'm flashing back to last month
when heat Maps look like this
welcome to 2022 a year when 99 of
companies lost value in a single day and
we're all saying but wait I'm
Diversified so why is my portfolio still
getting destroyed sure any single day
does not make the market but maybe we're
not Diversified in the right way you see
Goldman Sachs released a shocking report
just last week it claimed that the
classic 60 40 strategy of stocks and
bonds won't be enough it's down 34 this
year alone its worst performance in 100
years
as a result Goldman Sachs says that the
ideal allocation for stocks has shrunk
from 60 to around 45 percent
so what do they recommend that you do
with that difference in order to salvage
your disappearing returns invest in
tangible assets like art Goldman Sachs
says it can protect your purchasing
power even as prices rise and the last
time inflation was this High art
appreciated more than stocks and even
real estate at an incredible 17.5
percent per year no wonder Masterworks
has sold a painting as recently as this
month for an amazing 17.8 net return
even as inflation rages and stocks keep
sliding in fact the masterworks's last
three exits have all been pretty
incredible 17 21 and 33 net returns as a
result Masterworks has had to acquire
and release more art on their platform
to meet demand and there is a wait list
but you can skip it just by clicking the
link in the description and as always in
everything related to investment use
your head nothing is ever risk-free
[Music]
the Norwegian exception
[Music]
Norway is currently the world's largest
exporter of salmon exporting it to more
than 100 countries but it is not only
salmon that is exported Norway is a
major producer of dinosaur juice and gas
although we all love salmon it is
hydrocarbons that account for 40 to 70
of Norway's exports and which have made
Norway such a wealthy country it was not
easy to find oil in Norway during the
1960s they drilled more than 200
boreholes until they found a deposit the
eco-fisk oil field and I know what many
of you are thinking especially those of
you who are already familiar with visual
economic our Channel devoted to
economics a country discovers oil watch
out they could fall into the curse of
Natural Resources that's right having a
lot of natural resources does not mean
that you will become rich in many cases
the opposite is actually true but we
explain this in detail in a visual
economic video which I'll link for you
in the description below however Norway
is neither Russia nor Venezuela it is a
very special case listen up
[Music]
in 1972 Norway created the state-owned
oil company State oil now called Equinox
in 2001 State oil delisted part of its
shares on the Oslo and New York stock
exchanges but the government still held
81.7 ownership then in 2007 came a
merger with the oil and gas division of
Norse Hydro Norway's leading hydropower
producer right now the Norwegian State
owns just over 68 of Equinox naturally
this company distributes dividends which
are mostly collected by the Norwegian
government of course that's not the only
public Revenue stream the Norwegian
government also co-owned many of the
country's oil and gas Fields while taxes
on profits from the exploitation of
crude oil are extremely high in
particular the state can keep more than
75 percent off the profits in other
words when it comes to oil in Norway the
biggest beneficiary is always the state
and the question is what have they done
with all that money
well in 1990 Norway created the
so-called Norwegian Sovereign fund a
state investment fund for the purpose of
investing Surplus oil and gas revenues
and why you may ask well because this
Sovereign well-founded cushions all
crises oil price drops no problem Norway
has investments in all kinds of assets
assets that of course have nothing to do
with oil this fund is managed by a
division of the Norwegian Central Bank
what may surprise many of you is that
Norway Sovereign wealth fund is the
largest Sovereign wealth Fund in the
world alongside China's main fund and
Abu dhabi's fund take a look at this
chart
to give you an idea in 2013 the fund
represented the equivalent of 183 and in
2022 it already represents more than 225
of their GDP but not only that unlike
state-owned programs in other countries
this fund has had almost constant growth
they have even made significant returns
in the wake of the coveted pandemic and
low oil prices but how much oil does
Norway produce you may ask well not very
much
globally Norway produces approximately
two percent of the oil consumed and
three percent of the gas this is far
behind the production of countries such
as the United States Saudi Arabia Russia
Canada and Brazil among many others to
give you an idea in 2021 Saudi Arabia
produced around 9 million barrels of oil
per day the United States 11 million
Canada 4.7 million and Norway about 1.7
million barrels however Norway is the
third largest exporter of gas in the
World Behind only Russia and Qatar
in any case its point of difference it's
Secret in respect to other countries has
been based on being one of the few
countries that invests in the stock
market and diversifies its profits from
oil and gas in this way the government
is practically guaranteeing the future
of Norwegians and the fact is that as a
rule governments are net debtors that is
they have debts with the rest of the
world for example in the case of the
United States the public debt is
equivalent to some 93 000 per U.S
citizen in the case of Italy it is
equivalent to more than fifty thousand
dollars and in the case of Spain it is
equivalent to more than thirty thousand
dollars well in Norway the situation is
completely different do you know how
much each Norwegian would pay in public
debt absolutely nothing they could pay
off the entire public debt of the
country with the money from The
Sovereign fund and still have more than
one hundred and eighty thousand dollars
left for each Norwegian
[Music]
both right-wing and left-wing parties
have been conservative with the fund and
have not squandered it something
difficult to imagine in other countries
where coming to power often means
sharing the spoils in order to win votes
the first withdrawal of money from The
Sovereign wealth fund came in 2016 when
780 million dollars was spent to counter
an economic recession caused by low oil
prices in this way Norway barely noticed
the oil shock to put it another way if
there is a new oil crisis that would
make other producing countries suffer a
lot Norway could afford to not even be
touched by such a crisis do you want to
hear a fact that could make your head
explode in 2021 the Norwegian government
earned about 30 billion dollars from oil
exploitation in the country it turns out
that the average return of the Norwegian
Sovereign wealth fund around 5.8 since
its Inception means that in a typical
year the state earns more than twice as
much from the fund's profits as it does
from oil revenues themselves in other
words Norway is already more dependent
on the fund than on oil the big saving
that saves Norway from the oil crisis
but beyond being very wealthy the
question is can Norway be the salvation
of a Europe heading for gasmageddon
we're going to look at that right now
[Music]
Norway to the rescue
[Music]
Norway was already a key partner of the
European Union before the war in Ukraine
and exported 20 of Europe's natural gas
supply up until last year Brussels was
asking Oslo to stop Drilling in the
Arctic for ecological reasons now
however Brussels is asking Oslo to take
oil and gas from wherever they can the
goal is to replace Russian gas with more
gas from Norway and other countries for
the time being Norway has already
pledged to increase exports to Europe in
order to address the energy crisis
Norway to raise hydrocarbon production
by 6.8 percent by 2023. this increase is
in addition to the increase already seen
in 2022. during this year Norway will
produce 8 more natural gas than in 2021.
in total the increase in oil and gas
production will be almost 15 in 2021 and
6.8 percent in 2023 almost 23 in just
two years so if we're talking conspiracy
theories again can you guess which
European country has benefited the most
from the Russian gas sanctions and the
sabotage of nordstream 1 exactly Norway
coincidentally a new Norwegian gas
pipeline was put into operation on the
1st of October the pipeline is called
Baltic and has already started carrying
gas from Norway through Denmark to
Poland the Baltic pipeline will
transport 10 bcms of gas per year to
Poland up until now Norway has been
meeting 20 of European gas demand but
this year it is estimated that it will
already be meeting 25 and next year the
percentage is expected to be even higher
what's more the Norwegian government
itself says the following there Europe
will need gas from other sources than
Russia and in that perspective I think
it's hard to see that there are many
places where it's more natural to
continue to import gas from and a
European context than from Norway for us
it's important that they know and we
show them that Norway is a reliable
trustworthy and long-term energy partner
for Europe Andreas Magellan Erickson
state Secretary and Norway's Ministry
for petroleum and energy and Equinox has
already said it will increase production
but wait a minute one always giving
Europe a little breathing space from its
gasmageddon it won't be the ultimate
solution for the time being
[Music]
sometimes desire is not power in Norway
they are rubbing their hands with all
the extra income and want to sell more
gas to a needy Europe the problem Norway
can't double its gas production
overnight and not only that before the
war there were even those who said that
we should stop extracting hydrocarbons
as soon as 2035. okay this was the case
of the greens but take note because
although the labor party itself which is
now in government did not set a specific
date it was in favor of negotiating it
in other words there was not much
incentive to invest in the country's oil
and gas industry in other words it is
impossible to turn around years of
disinvestment in a few months in
addition one thing that has made it
difficult to buy gas in Europe is
European regasification capacity a quick
way to supply gas is to buy liquefied
natural gas there would be no need to
wait to build new pipelines with Norway
or other countries but the eu's
regatification capacity is insufficient
Germany which consumes the most gas in
the EU did not have a single
regasification plant before the
Ukrainian war and of course Norway does
not have sufficient liquefaction
capacity either because LNG has to be
liquefied first and then regassified you
need capacity at both ends of the
transportation chain but another way
Europe needs much more gas than Norway
can offer in the short term in other
visual politic videos we explain in more
detail what liquefied natural gas is and
what the various alternatives are that
Europe is getting to try to counteract
the energy crisis Europe is diversifying
its gas purchases and preparing to
receive liquefied natural gas from
different countries but now the big
question is in Norway are they being
supportive or is there some vested
interest behind it is there some dark
globalist agenda behind it all
foreign
Monopoly
[Music]
as we said at the beginning of the video
Norway is making a lot of money out of
the war in Ukraine they are making gold
without having to go looting like the
Viking Olaf so what does this mean for
Norway's Sovereign wealth fund and the
global economy well watch out because in
2023 alone the Norwegian government
expects to earn more than 130 million
dollars from the exploitation of crude
oil and natural gas and that's not all
at the moment revenues for 2022 are
estimated at almost 120 billion dollars
and do you know how much they earned in
2021 a little less than 30 billion in
other words thanks to the war in Ukraine
Norway will receive in 2022 and 2023 the
equivalent income of eight regular years
and you know what a large part of this
income will be earmarked for its
Sovereign wealth fund and this is no
joke Norway already owns 1.3 of all
shares in the world companies such as
Nestle apple and Microsoft have the
Norwegian Sovereign wealth fund as one
of their largest shareholders and stay
tuned because here comes the really
interesting part one advantage of being
a shareholder of a company is that if
you have enough shares you can influence
its direction well until a few years ago
this Sovereign wealth fund did not
pursue any influence over the companies
in which it invested let's say that it
limited itself to excluding certain
types of companies from its portfolio
basically arms manufacturers producers
of hydrocarbons tobacco coal or
companies with dubious links to Human
Rights something that of course it
continues to do
[Music]
for example the fund recently put
Canada's Bombardier and South Korea's
Hyundai glovis on a watch list for
possible sale from its investments in
the case of Hyundai it was because of
its alleged use of scrap yards in
Pakistan and Bangladesh where labor
conditions border on human right
violations at least according to the
fund in the case of Bombardier the
reason was some suspicions of corruption
in various countries then this same fund
has also had controversies with the
Chinese government they divested all
shares in the sports company Lee ning
due to an apparent violation of human
rights in the xinjiang region
however for some time now the fun
strategy has begun to change we have
evolved from being a reluctant owner to
a more active owner in the beginning the
idea was simply to buy a slice of the
global financial markets and Our
intention was not to exert any influence
over the company's Turon Grande Deputy
CEO of the Norwegian Sovereign wealth
fund for example it is no longer unusual
for this farmers to publish in advance
how it's going to vote on certain issues
at shareholder meetings in order to
generate pressure they supposedly do
this to improve corporate governance our
goal is to strengthen companies through
better governance and improve their
long-term risk management trond grandi
Deputy CEO of the Norwegian Sovereign
wealth fund along these lines in 2021
the Norwegian fund voted in six
resolutions at the Facebook shareholders
meetings for Facebook to be more
transparent and to present improved
reporting however right here is the
potentially most disturbing issue that
from purely corporate issues the
Norwegian fund moves on to pressuring
companies with more cultural Identity or
political issues in other words that it
tries to import Norwegian values into
the companies in which it invests for
example in 2022 the Norwegian fund voted
in favor of a human rights report and a
pay Gap report at Disney's shareholder
meeting and something similar happened
to Amazon
[Music]
Norway was on the side of Amazon workers
who wanted to set up a union in fact at
a shareholders meeting Norway voted in
favor of collective bargaining rights
against the interests of Jeff Bezos
himself as a side note I will tell you
that in this case Norway lost the vote
and it did so among other reasons
because the funds Holdings in companies
tends to be relatively small but of
course when you have so much money what
you say within a company is at the very
least taken into account and you can
become a trendsetter many other funds
and shareholders may decide to copy you
they put it in a nutshell Norway in the
stock market is like the popular kid at
school who sets Trends and not only that
if necessary this fund could buy larger
stakes in certain companies in order to
be able to influence them much more
believe me with more than one trillion
dollars in your Investment Portfolio you
could do almost anything you want
another example well you see Norway is
not only one of the richest countries in
the world it is also one of the most
egalitarian and it is precisely this
social model that they try to bring to
their companies in fact do you know what
one of the major causes Norway is
fighting for exactly the salary of
managers Norway has been pressuring
companies for years to other high
salaries they pay to their managers this
means one thing the Norwegian Sovereign
wealth fund could end up becoming a
nightmare for CEOs that's why headlines
like this one don't come as a surprise
world's largest Sovereign wealth fund to
vote against Apple's CEO Tim Cook's pay
package and keep in mind the problem is
that you can start with the salary of
managers and end up with many other
initiatives let's say that if necessary
Norway could use the fund as a political
weapon in One Direction or the other
[Music]
this year the fund announced that it
will liquidate all its Russian assets
we're talking about 2.8 billion dollars
it's not a large sum if we compare it
with the other Investments they have in
other countries but there it is and
logically the more money the fund has
the more influence it has so if one
thing is clear it is that the huge
torrent of money that is now pouring
into the lands of fjords will if
anything greatly increase that influence
there are those who have harshly
criticized the Norwegian Sovereign
wealth fund for Its Behavior why because
pursuing political or ideological
interests when investing can result in
Lost returns and this could be bad news
for Norwegians themselves of course if
we're talking about criticism Norway has
also been strongly criticized for the
large revenues they are earning from the
war Poland's own prime minister has
pointed out that Norway is benefiting
directly from the war and urged them to
share this New Wealth with Ukraine but
whatever the case now the question is
for you will Norway help Ukraine more or
will they seek to invest more in their
Sovereign wealth fund will Norway manage
to produce more gas to save Europe from
the energy crisis what will be the next
moves of the Norwegian Sovereign wealth
fund you can leave me your answers in
the comment and as always don't forget
they're here on visualpolitik we release
new videos every week so subscribe to
the channel hit that little bell icon so
you don't miss any of our video updates
and if you like this video please like
it I'll see you in the next one take
care see you soon
[Music]